it didn't take long for residents at
Desert Garden Condominiums to talk as
many are now left figuring out their
next move in fear that their condo will
soon be next on The Chopping Block
when I first moved over here
grass security two pools Wash House
Nursery
all kind of roses you can name that was
Perry Williams a resident for over 30
years describing how things used to look
at Desert Garden Condominiums and if
you've been around the property lately
it's not hard to tell it's been a ghost
town as tenants have been leaving left
and right with broken windows doors
tagged and tons of trash and debris and
empty lots the Desert Garden condos have
been operating for decades on the west
side of town but recently were purchased
by Ahern Rentals who decided to knock
them down for reasons unknown at this
time in my opinion looked at these
people as nothing we're not trying to
stop you from doing what you want to do
but just be fair about it if you want
the people to leave give them a fair way
out and those who have lived here for
years feel as if they're being pushed
out with demolition already in the works
many even offered money for their keys
Williams who lives on a fixed income
after retiring last year says if only he
had been told sooner but now he and his
wife are left with little to no options
all they had to do just tell me this was
going on I know I'm probably the only
one who's paying my rent six months in
advance I guarantee you but are you
moving I got to I got to uh be homeless
I don't want to be homeless
and we were told by Bartlett that Ahern
Rentals have provided an agency to help
relocate tenants but the process has
been less than helpful and we plan on
reaching out to the city tomorrow along
with the rental company to get more
information as to why desert Garden is
being torn down in The Newsroom Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now